so going back to that almost spite
fueled passion which I think it's great
because you know you you you say yes
people said hey go ahead go quote follow
your bliss you won't make it but do it
anyway they set it back home they set it
here how does one keep that engine going
without becoming too bitter because I
think that's a great we hear it all the
time whatever creative endeavor oh we
can't really make money at it but yeah
try it yeah you know I like our
instrument in a lot of ways it's a
muscle and you you keep strengthening it
and once you invest in that you know
when you set your course or strike the
canvas that you're going to stick you
begin to reinforce that muscle and
hopefully the business responds enough
or opportunity responds enough that
you're engaged
in the industry I call it a membrane and
for a long time we slide through it and
we get to visit and do a little work and
then we get pushed back out so it takes
a long time to get inside the membrane
and stay inside the membrane but I in
answer to your question about the the
bitterness
you know it's filtered disappointment it
just is every time I really want a job
and it's the hardest thing as an actor
because when when I really want a job
I squeeze the sawdust out it into the
bad I try too hard and I get in my own
way and they say one of the first things
they say in acting school is leave
yourself alone don't get in your own way
trust yourself you know and it it's hard
not to be hopefully you move from from
bitterness to disappointment or
resentment to disappointment and from
disappointment to engagement and
engagement to satisfaction but that's a
lot of moving you know and in it and
it's never a pure line I think it slides
back and forth to be honest so when you
feel yourself sliding more toward
that may be some of the negative aspects
how do you get yourself back on track
still with that drive still ok I'm gonna
prove that I can do this especially in
the beginning
oh wow in the beginning you know III you
four mystically say you bite the stick
and hang on and whatever comes to shake
you off you just clamp down and honestly
I think it's more you know about your
stubbornness in the beginning because
you're you know there'll be
disappointments there'll be people that
mislead you a bit or at least you hear
what you want to hear maybe they're not
misleading but you know we we do this on
faith and we do it on hope and not a lot
of food and it it how you get through
that personally and and in the beginning
it was good to have other things to do
during the week I mean to be able to
work harp and tree to be able to you
know to physically exert myself as
something I think that helped break up
some of the noise in my own head I think
that's what you have to find is
something to ameliorate that noise
because if you don't and it gets louder
and louder and louder it's crippling
maybe I don't care if it's the
bitterness or the you know the fantasy
what it's supposed to be there's a great
old saying I think there's a wonderful
songwriter named Eliza Gill Kissin and
it one of her songs she says sometimes
the big dream has to die for the little
dream to thrive and I think that's true
for a lot of us we come out with this
big dream about what it's supposed to
look like and what you can let go of
that your little dreams can begin to
thaw for I and and some of that
bitterness and resentment and stuff can
go away you can just go
you